this is the damage caused by Russian
drone strikes on the Ukrainian Port of
Ismail on the denip river tons of grains
spilled from at least two destroyed
silos the latest attack on Ukraine's
grain infrastructure
firefighters worked hard but the damage
will take time to repair
Ismail across the Danube from NATO
member Romania has been the major route
out of Ukraine for grain shipments since
the collapse of the Black Sea grain deal
last month there are alternatives mostly
by land but they're costly and slow
grain prices have risen by 15 percent in
the last two weeks as the crisis deepens
Russia is actually in a better position
now than it was last year because as we
saw with the the oil tankers going Asia
to Asia Russia has found alternative
ways to export its grain VIA Rail lines
for example the main north south
transport Line is now open down to the
Iranian Port of bander Abbas so it's
found alternatives for its grain
hours after the attack the Russian
president spoke with his Turkish
counterpart reject type arjon Vladimir
Putin confirmed he would reinstate the
grain initiative as soon as Russia's
interests are upheld by the West as was
made clear by his spokesman
[Music]
Russia and President Putin has already
said this hundred times we are ready to
return to the deal immediately it's just
that the deal must be implemented in
terms of the part that concerns Russia
so far this hasn't been done
the grain deal was brokered by the U.N
and turkey last summer Moscow pulled out
of the agreement in July claiming that
the International Community had failed
to assure that Russia could freely
export grain and fertilizer the Turkish
president sees the Black Sea grain and
esteve as what he describes as a Bridge
of Peace but he is concerned over
actions that could escalate tensions the
two leaders decided to meet face to face
in Turkey despite the fact that Putin
hasn't left Russia since the start of
the war in Ukraine and an arrest warrant
was issued by the international criminal
court in March
there are growing signs Russia is
willing to come back to the negotiating
table as the crisis drags on and food
prices soar while Russia continues to
wage economic Warfare against Ukraine
cnmco solo Al jazeer Istanbul
or Julia chapovalova is in Moscow she
has more on the kremlin's reaction to to
Kia's attempt to restore the deal
president erdogan Keen to persuade his
Rush counterpart to resume the grain
deal and as the relationship between
Russia and turkey's vitally important
for both there is a glimmer of hope that
he will be successful President Putin
has confirmed his Readiness to return to
the grain deal as soon as Russia's
conditions are met at the same time
Russia continues destroying Ukrainian
Port infrastructure showing the world
it's not going to allow any food exports
from the Ukrainian Port without its
participation after having pulled out of
the grain deal it keeps its promise to
consider All Ships In the Black Sea
sailing to and from Ukraine's ports
potential carriers of military cargo
Russia says it destroys weapons arriving
at the Ukrainian ports from a number of
Western countries as part of military
aid to the country while the ukrainians
say Russia's targeting Ukraine's economy
too by not allowing it to export its
grain which used to bring Ukraine tens
of billions of dollars in profit as we
see currently Russia's hitting Ukraine's
support infrastructure last autumn and
winter Russia was destroying Ukraine's
Energy System before that there were
attacks on oil and gas refineries and
Railway facilities so it seems like all
that is part of Russia's Global strategy
aimed at destroying Ukraine's
infrastructure to force it to surrender